[Music]
hello is this the manager for the white
target I'm under the assistant managers
how can I help you well are you a
manager who can be capable of rectifying
problems or are you a shift manager who
will pass me off between smoking brakes
no no I'm okay I have a very serious
complaint what exactly happened
my daughter went into your target to
purchase a hat because she is out
selling girl-scout cookies that is what
she's doing right now I'm sure you're
aware of this going on to raise funds
for trips and other such festivities yes
are you a supporter of the Girl Scouts
yourself you were yeah let me ask you
this did they allow grown men into the
Girl Scouts back then I'm sorry into the
way that they allow fully grown adult
males into the Girl Scouts back then
when when you were participating would
that have made you uncomfortable okay
then why in the hell would you allow a
grown-ass man into the ladies room at
Target
well my nine-year-old daughter was there
trying to simply relieve herself so I'll
tell you that that's actually a
corporate issue and we have a gender
free policy for the restrooms this is
not the first complaint that I've
received for the restrooms it's just
something that the company allows now in
for if someone feels uncomfortable then
with you allow them to use the family
restroom it is not up front it's
actually near the pharmacy so I do
apologize you know for her being
uncomfortable I can see where you're
coming from but it is that's curious
term gender-free I'm not familiar what
does gender free mean for for whom it
applies target is not discriminate as a
company based on gender so we will allow
men women
transgender bisexual of any you know
gender into whichever restroom that they
prefer so it doesn't seem that you
discriminate against the idea of
discomfort for very young women around
possibly sexually predatorial
older males this man offered to help my
daughter relieve herself using the
restroom do you understand the only
reason she found out he was a man was
because he decided to piss in the stall
next to her standing up it sounded like
a damn fire hose okay that's actually
something else can you tell me that is
something else it is something else with
which I'm entirely unfamiliar and
forgive me for being completely in
polkadot a dress and then lifted up his
skirt to reveal what can only be
described as an acorn squash which has
been left in the Sun too long that's how
my daughter came back and described it
to me do you understand that when I send
my daughter in to buy a hat to Target
I'm not expect her to come out in need
of a biology lesson right okay so can
you tell me when this happened because
but that actually sounds you know like
something that we don't want happening
at the store we do allow you know anyone
into the restroom that they prefer but
if that's happening in those restrooms
we need to make sure that we know what's
going on so can you tell me when she
came in yes she came in on Tuesday
somewhere between 1 and 3 o'clock may I
ask a follow-up question if it is your
policy to allow people to use any
restroom by which they identify as some
made-up terminology that you've
attempted to describe very
unsuccessfully with gender if that is
target's policy please do tell pray how
could you expect this not to happen you
know sir I wish I had a better response
to your follow-up question right now and
I wish I had a daughter at nine years
old who had yet to see a penis so we
both have things were yearning for that
we cannot achieve in this
lifetime at this point forward you
understand right now I completely
understand some some you know we are
gender free policy restroom not everyone
agrees with it and we understand that so
I you know I spend offense with you and
where you're coming from on this what I
am concerned with is that this behavior
went on in the restroom and we weren't
told about it so you know we've had
other people before come in as you know
what our gender policy is in the
restroom that is accurate you were told
about it you were informed about it just
now when was I informed about it just
now this is how that occurs these are
there's something that adults use
referred to as communication generally
that requires a verbal a transmission of
some variety you understand that is what
is occurring at the present oh yeah I'm
talking about
whenever the accident actually happened
you know we were not informed about it
and if we were informed about it you
know I was not here that day so I want
to know exactly would have an accident
is not the word I would use for this man
who I can only assume his name it
Charles
or Bob you see I'm being somewhat
facetious but accident is not the term I
would use for a man who went out there
with a blueprint on how to show the
young ladies his nan who has this seems
very very much like a far cry from an
accident an accident might be my
daughter dropped a pair of pants while
she was looking through perusing the
young girl's eye an accident is not a
man dropping his ducking ball in the
ladies restroom okay so can I ask you
one other question I am open to all
possibilities at this point all can you
does she describe what the man was like
scary frightening daddy what anything
what happened daddy what is that daddy
why is that different from what I use to
tinkle hey daddy why is there some
thread where I have a space hey daddy
what what is that supposed to do is that
why I can't pee
standing up hey daddy where can i buy
one of those hey daddy that looks fun
these are not questions I want to have
to answer my nine-year-old daughter you
understand no I just want to know if you
can describe what this man was wearing
or you know how he came in because I
want to make sure I take this up with a
P do you have any idea how impossible it
is for me to allow my daughter moving
forward to use a computer my god
all she wants to Google is what she saw
in that bathroom and I don't know it
doesn't if you're familiar with Google
or Bing if that's your search engine of
preferred choice but it doesn't matter
how many image filters you put on that
by god is still an unsafe query great
okay well what I'm trying to do here is
just try to solve this problem and see
what exactly happened we don't have
cameras in the restroom but we have a
camera leading outside and I would just
like to check and make sure that we know
who this individual was sure I will
accept cash okay so could you describe
to me what he was wearing or did your
daughter tell you no can she remember
anything at all what he what he look
like that day would any variances in my
description determine in fact what
payout is offered on this phone call so
I'm gonna make sure I check with ap
first of all to see that this event did
occur and then after that I'll have to
talk to the rest of the managers to see
what further action is going to be taken
about it to see if this and if this in
fact did occur so that becomes at that
point a matter of conjecture a he
said/she well he said it said situation
okay he said she with a [ __ ] said
situation a he said and she with male
genitalia entirely functioning peeing
standing up next to nine-year-old girl
said matter of conjecture a he said and
she sexually predatory ly possibly
molesting women in the restroom and an
ongoing basis at the
target said you understand the problem
yeah if this happened you know that's a
problem it's not something that you know
is just the gender policy Android
something that concerns you know a
sexual predator so I want to make sure
that all he did was pee standing up so
is it gender free unless in fact you
urinate while standing I mean you know
whenever you go to the restroom
typically you're not urinating into the
sink so urinating in a stall no no he
did not eliminate into the sink he
urinated into the stall that's how my
daughter was made aware that it was a
man you understand she had never once in
her life experienced somebody urinating
standing up it sounded like a pool pump
set on high he never urinated into the
sink he simply paid standing up into the
toilet and and then the questions arose
you understand
so then was your daughter exposed to
this in the same stall she was not in
the same stall okay so then how did she
see this prison genitalia afterward he
was making an adjustment I believe so
she didn't get into graphic detail I
assume she's tried to block some of it
out okay so then how was she able to
describe the exact you know this man did
not actively molester
he simply urinated standing up and there
was enough discomfort that my daughter
was made aware that this was a man and
then he offered to help her wash her
hands frankly I'd like to wash my hands
of this entire memory and conversation
okay so your daughter was not in the
same stole correct she was not in the
same stall that were the case we'd be
talking about a murder trial okay
well what I can do is what I just told
you man I can take it up with a pee just
to make sure go ahead and do that and
then I will call back
next time I will be calling back with a
lawyer to ensure that security footage
has been pulled and I tell you what I
will bring little Cindy over there and
maybe someone can personally offer her
an apology how about that that might be
a start
I mean we'd be more than willing to do
that I do need to know forgiveness how
many Girl Scout cookies grant purchase
when she comes in how many do you think
right
how many girls Scout cookies do you plan
on purchasing when she comes in I'll
have her bring that in that might take
some measures to rectify sure you can
only promise that full grown men with
penises will continue to use the fifth
women's restroom but God forbid god
forbid you pony up for a Samoa
however the store managers have a say
you know in what we can do to comfort
the guests so like I said if she was if
she felt uncomfortable you know we do
equally apologize for that let me point
in a way that you might understand she
felt about as uncomfortable with it as
apparently Target does with the
Salvation Army Santa's who you so
unceremoniously kicked to the curb the
fundamental difference between the two
situations being that the Salvation Army
Santa's were not revealing their dicks
to the American public I have no comment
on that I just want to make sure that I
get this story straight so that I can
follow up with AP is that okay you can
follow up with AP I appreciate you
taking the time have a good day hey this
video is taken to the clip from the full
show Daily Show at ladder with
credit.com slash mug club where it's
available exclusively $69 a year that's
less than $6 a month less than two
expensive cups of coffee or you can feed
an African child but just by coffee or
join the mug Club Daily Show ladder with
credit.com slash mug club see you there
don't feed children
you